it's a real special pleasure for me to
join you this afternoon
for a lecture by dr. Gus Casely Hayford
he's you know as the director of the
Smithsonian National Museum of African
art before I say a few words about our
distinguished speaker let me share with
you why his visit is so important to us
and why it is especially significant his
lecture today honors two important
initiatives at Yale as many of you know
when I became president in 2013 I
announced the Yale Africa initiative
effect it was in my inaugural address
and I said that with the growing
influence of the African continent on
the world economy as well as the
increase in migration to and from and
within Africa it was an important moment
an important moment to bring scholarship
and teaching about Africa at Yale into
sharper focus and so working
collaboratively we knew that we could
foster New Directions in research on
Africa identify new partnerships with
those on the continent strengthen our
recruitment efforts all while
emphasizing teaching and learning and so
in 2018 I was thrilled to be able to
meet with key partners and stakeholders
in that initiative in Ghana and in Kenya
and from conversations that came out of
that visit and others with African
leaders and scholars and alumni I
learned about just how excuse-me diverse
our research and educational
partnerships in Africa were and could
become and how we could advance shared
goals concerning new knowledge
concerning important discoveries and
maybe most importantly preparing the
next generation of leaders so I continue
to feel strongly that our engaged
with Africa should be an important
dimension to the university's mission a
mission that you know is about research
about teaching about preservation and
practice I'm very proud of the fact that
just since that initial speech in 2013
we've doubled the number of African
students and scholars on this campus
we've launched new partnerships in and
with African universities for African
universities for example have joined the
school of management's global network
for Advanced Management
I will Pericles Louis our vice president
for global strategy will be going to
Africa this year I will likely go back
in another year from now and I feel that
we're really on a roll
most importantly though those are
genuine partnerships we look for
opportunities where we can offer
something African university or
institution or agency can offer
something and we both do something
together that we wouldn't have done
separately it's wonderful that this
lecture is taking place in partnership
with the Council on African Studies here
at the Macmillan Center this is the
council I think many of you know you
many of you are affiliated with it that
is focused on teaching and research on
all things Africa and as a key partner
for the Yale African Initiative I should
also point out for those of you who
don't know a team Andrea is sitting
right here and he is the Office of
Institutional office of international
affairs director for the African
Initiative and for those of you who have
never met him but have some ideas about
partnerships he is your guy to talk to I
I sense by your chuckles you all know
who he is so I will also say if you see
us later Eddie and I did not coordinate
on our ties today although he is wearing
the green version of the same tie I'm
wearing today in a blue version
dr. Casely a ford's visit also honors
another kind of partnership and that's
what the smithsonian and that is an
enduring partnership yale and the
smithsonian have a deep and abiding
commitment to collaborative work and
this extends back to the earliest days
of these institutions so James Dwight
data Yale College graduate and later a
member of our faculty was the
meteorologists and geologist of the
United States exploring expedition whose
collections form the basis of the
founding of the Smithsonian
Institution's OSI March who Marsh who is
Yale graduate our first professor of
paleontology was the first federal
paleontologist appointed to the US
Geological Survey
half of his collection is on this campus
and half of it forms the collection
forms a collection within the
Smithsonian so if you look at dinosaurs
they're or dinosaurs here you're
basically looking at marshes excavations
in 2016 we formalized a new partnership
with the Smithsonian in addition to
conservation and the protection of
cultural heritage that is threatened
worldwide our new alliance also focuses
on the digital humanities on race and
human diversity and on climate change I
think there are going to be ripple
effects of our collaboration that extend
beyond the two institutions especially
through public education and through
other kinds of outreach where we
celebrate and share our core objectives
so as the director of the nation's
premier museum devoted to the arts of
Africa from antiquity to the present
dr. Casey Hayford knows better than
anyone else the importance of preserving
the Heritage's and legacies of so many
generations he joined the museum in
February 2018
with him a wealth of experience writing
lecturing and broadcasting on Africa's
arts and cultures he is born in London
he was educated at the School of
Oriental and African Studies at the
University of London and he received his
doctorate there in African history he
sits on the board of several arts
institutions and in 2018 he was
presented with an Order of the British
Empire Award for his work on Africa dr.
Casey Hayford is a prominent expert on
African arts and has been featured on
the BBC including two seasons of the
popular lost kingdoms of Africa
television series as well as a 20-17
tEDGlobal talk which focused on the
powerful stories that shape Africa and
this TED talk has been viewed by over a
million viewers he's the author of a new
lady bird expert book Timbuktu and I
can't tell you how thrilled we are that
you are joining us here today at Yale
let us welcome dr. Casey
[Applause]
let me take my talk but it's wonderful
to be here
and I was coming up these coast on the
train yesterday and I could I was
following on Twitter this huge Bank of
snow that was barreling up the coast
behind us and the the the previous talk
that I did was actually in Chicago and
it was over that weekend it was minus 20
and I didn't actually know that the
temperature could go down that far and
the lake froze over and so it's
something obviously to do with me so I
apologize before I start for the weather
but the the warmth of the reception that
I've got here has been the fantastic
counterbalance to the weather I just
want to thank everyone it's a great
honor to be here I mean I've followed
the work of so many of the academics
that have worked for Yale and to visit
it has always been a dream and I'd want
to thank Marta and Peter who've hosted
me just so wonderfully so warmly all our
colleagues at Yale it's just been a
glorious visit and also my dear
colleagues from the Smithsonian who've
accompanied me and also who are a
fantastic illustration of the breadth
and the complexity of the partnerships
that house two institutions enjoy and I
want to be a part of that I'm fairly new
in post but I look forward to engaging
in rich partnerships over many years of
my tenure and I want to say thank you
for inviting me thank you for coming I
couldn't be on more honored or delighted
I know the quality of the intellectual
investment that you've made this
institution in Africa and I've followed
the successful delivery of the Yale
Africa initiative and I know the
particular personal investment that you
Peter have made of being in that unique
position of
being the only Ivy League president to
have professionally visited Africa to
invested so much in building
relationships with the continent and I
know from the responses from across a
variety of different sorts of
institutions different sorts of people
across the African continent how valued
your commitment has been thank you thank
you so much for your leadership and I I
come here this my first time but I feel
so at home here and before I start I
just I think I want to share something
that I'm really passionate about a real
passion of mine something that I do
and my role is equal parts crazy and
equal parts wonderful and inspirational
and there are moments when I have to
escape my office and there are a few
things that I've come to quietly rely
upon and before I start my rock might my
day or if I find a few moments between
meetings you'll often find me because I
retreat to the gallery to visit these
old friends these two stately weathered
figures they once sat either side of a
Nigerian slit gong it's a century old
wooden drum that was designed to speak
to hear the sound of a well-played gong
at close quarters is something that at
least in my mind is hard to forget
it's like thunder rolling across your
ribcage and it creates a kind of it's a
very particular sound deep sonorous
tones that were conceived to open up a
very special and particular realm of
communication a sphere of music and
poetry which is sometimes so deeply
importantly organic that it can weave a
palpable link between drummer and
listener between drummer and history
between listener and message calling
people to dance whilst simultaneously
forming the rhythm of the dance itself
binding communities together with
drummed messages with histories with
proverbs and in spite of consciously
trying not to have favorites these
wonderful objects seem to draw me back
again and again and I know that you have
a drum of a similar age in the
collection here from the same region and
these are beguiling things and slipped
logs or drums they are in one sense the
simplest of musical instruments and that
simplicity is their wonder like all
drums when force is brought to bear upon
a surface a kind of percussive energy is
transmitted through the atmosphere to
impact the tympanic membrane at the
middle ear but then these drums they
have a surprise for you hitting the
listener with a secondary wave of sound
an energy that resonates up through the
ground rising up through the solar
plexus into the chest cavity and the
fact its immediate and it's utterly
intoxicating when these aural explosions
are combined and arranged into passages
it's utterly thrilling it could feel
like the purest analog of being itself I
mean our bodies they crave rhythms beats
mirror the explosions in the deepest
muscles of the heart we relish their
immutability their irreducibility their
energy we know to anticipate the rise
and impending beat we crave the
sensation of the impact of a tone on the
air and lament the collapse of a sound
when we're left in that very particular
aural vacuum between beats as tone gives
way to potent momentary silence it's the
most a basic epistemological statement
after a beat biological necessity there
must be that space in which the beat can
be there must be silence the chance to
catch a breath to regain our composure
and drummers in this part of Nigeria
they really know what they're doing they
know how to play and control that
silence in its varied and create and and
creative forms silence is important in
March traditional African music the
lacunae the skipping a beat or a
momentary silence is significant not
just because of it it's a mechanical
break in the sound but because of what
it can uniquely invoke for the listener
in many of the most celebrated African
drumming languages silence is not seen
as this as the as the field upon which
sound is placed silence is an equal and
active component of overall composition
what can be suggested by the quality of
a momentary silence is completely unique
as some African drummers they've taken
that idea of an active silence to its
extraordinary conclusion they've learned
to collude with the silence and the
interference between multiple rhythms to
collaborate with that alter rhythm to
entice it from the aural shadows
finessing and focusing patterns of
particular sounds and even though no
single drama might control these rhythms
this distinct field of resonance is said
to have a dynamic and responsive quality
all of its own it's been called by many
musicologists the inside rhythm it's a
ghostly musical presence that seemed to
manif seems to manifest itself within
musical space and silences and the
mechanics and the history of the inside
rhythm are somewhat mysterious but the
politics of silence
for me sits at a Nexus of significant
cultural phenomena connected to emitted
histories to lost narrative and to
marginalization silence loss and
omission in African history are powerful
things Foucault wrote memorably about
the relationship between power and
knowledge about how the label of madness
had been used to systematically silence
the poor well for peoples of African
descent we've had to deal with simile
pervasive and destructive connotations
of labels labels would have which have
been used to malign and silence us
indeed for many peoples of African
descent who suffered through enslavement
through colonialism and the destruction
and conversation of drums drums became a
powerful analog of that loss of voice
and perhaps what makes this object so
poignant that draws be back to it again
and again is that sense of that
lingering ghostly inside rhythm and
whilst the pain of the intolerable
silence of these instruments can be
poignant we can work to retell the
stories of the figures that once sat
upon them to make them sing again we
know or we can deduce something of this
this particular drums story from the
weather-worn surface of the carved
figures we know that it probably reached
the end of its useful life but although
it was divided into pieces and long
separated through collaborative research
we can give these glorious objects back
some life we can reunite them with their
story we can find that inside rhythm
that lingering rhythm the archaeology of
the story that might have been lost for
more than three decades the left-hand
figure mottled with an weathered
the left hand figure which is a female
figure sitting with her baby in her
cross lab was carved by an in been Bay
artist in southeast Nigeria and it's
been a major part of our collection for
a number of years but a few years ago
the female the female figure was sent on
loan to the Metropolitan Museum of Art
it was placed adjacent to a figure from
a collection in Germany
unlike long-lost twins they seemed to
immediately connect and through
considerable collaborative research
through multi continental consultation
through dendrochronology we were able to
confirm that these two wooden figures
thought to be late 19th century likely
sat back-to-back at either end of a
massive slit gong and although they
belong together rot ruin reuniting them
was simultaneously odd they sit back to
back as if just after a row yet they're
also obviously a couple locked together
in love like so much west african art
they are balanced opposing forces that
tell a kind of dynamic truth because of
that opposition knowing that we could
reunite the couple one male one female
to repose them in their eternal feud is
thrilling the drum might have been
silenced the figures might not be
talking but good musial adji has made
them sing although they make no sound
they've left an exquisite lingering
poignant inside rhythm the enlightenment
philosophers who crafted the
intellectual culture that underpins both
conventional Museo de and academia
simply excluded Africa from the pantheon
of classical civilizations its most
respected men members men like Hegel and
Kant figures like Locke and Hume wrote
that when they look to Africa to find
recognizable forms of Internet
to tradition they simply couldn't find
what they sought at the cultural
archaeology of that historic willful
blindness to African intellectual
achievement that silencing of African
voices is still evidence its legacy
still impacts our understanding of the
world and the cultural sector has
seemingly been a willing ally of this
system of exquisitely crafted racism
within our lifetimes respected museums
have overtly or implicitly accommodated
social Darwinism we have as a sector
even house taxidermied human beings to
illustrate racial hierarchies and many
institutions continue to deal poorly
with the problematic with problematic
historic collections these things leave
a lingering odor over our discipline our
sector continues to be weighed down by
difficult issues that haunt us that
limit our ability to be effective in
ways that we know that we should and
that archaeology of historic racism is
only made worse by our sectors inability
to deal with ongoing structural
inequalities a recent research project
led by the Smithsonian surveyed Natural
History Museum's across the world was
able to quantify something that we
probably all Intuit
the Natural History Museum's of Europe
and North America are home to more than
90% of the agglomerative global
collection yet ironically the source for
a high proportion of those objects is
the global south it's a stark and
uncomfortable reality the vast majority
of what we see in our most celebrated
Natural History Museum's was collected
in regions with the weakest educational
and museu logical provision the
inequalities we see mapped out in global
economics are reflected in exaggerated
forms in museums the most well-off
continued to benefit from the cultural
and intellectual blessings of the least
runoff we see that vividly replicated in
African visual arts where the huge
imbalance
in resource in quality and in scale of
collections in many parts of the
continent seem to seem to imperil
Africans from delivering meaningfully
around African art telling the story of
African art and when one looks at
regional or state collections compares
them between Africa and Europe it's
difficult to travel in the region as an
academic and hold one's head up high in
Europe and North America ironically
conversely the sheer scale the sheer
complexity of key collections creates
challenges of display of storage of
interpretation the silence imposed by
colonialism by slavery by what has
followed has not been alleviated
critical areas of African culture remain
imperiled stifled or overlooked our
museum spent some time reflecting on and
surveying the African museum sector and
the resulting collected data tells a
story of chronic under resourcing of
areas of abject neglect but also of
pockets of enduring hope of excellence
and shoots of genuine wonder many
African music museums were in
substantive part established to fulfill
a function for colonial administration's
trying to make sense of regions so
they're often disparate and often
disaffected inhabitants between 1850 and
the end of the First World War as the
peer it was the period of the most
intense expansion of museums it's also a
generation of in which in which museums
that are focused around heritage come
into being and they seem to reflect and
rationalize what is happening with
Empire with the end of the First World
War and the beginning of the
disintegration of the colonial machine
it was investment in the first
generation of dedicated archeology and
art museums these were institutions that
began to meaningful
meaningfully acknowledged African
intellectual creative prowess to create
individual room for individual artistic
virtuosity and for regional
distinctiveness and they were
subsequently joined between independence
and the present day by a new kind of
African art museum institutions that
sought to be seen as platforms for the
promotion of post-colonial narratives
and they consciously forged new
histories promoted African movements art
movements and also offered platforms for
discrete artists and it's fascinating in
my mind to see the discrete shifts
across time but if you what we did here
was to actually think about what was it
that drove the creation of these museums
and you begin to get a sense of how the
creation of museums was a process that
was deeply instrumentalized
and it looks even more particular when
one looks at cross the the period and
looks at the gears in which more than
three museums came into being you get a
sense of the reasons why museums were
being instituted the main periods are
the years leading up to the First World
War just before the Second World War
alongside independence during the
collapse of apartheid it seems that with
each discrete political shift museums
were created to reflect the moment and
often to speak to rather than to speak
for communities but over the course of
history if the data tells a single story
it's of the inexorable growth of the art
museum and the burgeoning of these art
museums has been mirrored with changes
in international markets with the rise
of African art college colonies and
African art collectives and the growth
of more globally minded dealers and
galleries who began to look to Africa
for new ideas and they've attracted
collectors who in recent years have seen
spectacular returns on their investments
as once Nisha
artists have joined a generation of
international art superstars African art
has become cool and the best African art
news were very expensive but as ever the
main beneficiaries of these changes have
been audiences have been collectors have
been institutions beyond the continent I
mean this is wonderful and
simultaneously frustrating and we've
seen similar kinds of shifts with power
of parallel manifestations in many areas
of creative expression where does
someone like jay-z sample is most
radical riffs and rhythms
where does Bond Beyonce borrow her dance
steps hollywood looks look for its
marvel superheroes fashion borrow its
most vivid textiles africa is cool it's
exploding with ideas with talent and
that energy has percolated out beyond
the trendy to reset the mainstream and
whilst you can visit the global art
fairs and see this phenomenon vividly
reflected in the state-sponsored africa
museum sector it just simply hasn't
managed to resonate all the way through
to the museum's that matter much of the
wider sector is failing or struggling
and this is frustrating but placed in
its historical context it's more than
frustrating it feels wrong in the
opening scenes of black panther there's
a robbery at a barely disguised British
Museum and there's a moment when Eric
Hill manga Stephens played by Michael B
Jordan and he stands in front of a
museum display in these examining a
selection of carvings and then the
museum director approaches and I was
talking to this about about this to my
colleague Chris and the thing that she
really was annoyed about was the museum
director was drinking a cup of tea at
the time as well so you know this is an
appalling museum director but anyway
and she approaches and she offers to
tell kill manga about the works and kill
manga he quickly stops and he corrects
her and explains that a 7th century war
hammer hammer wasn't actually fuller as
he says it was taken by the British
soldiers in Benin but actually is from
Wakanda and then I'm because in my mind
I could do this with an American accent
but I'm not sure I have the guts to
actually do that in front of people I'm
in a British accent it really sounds bad
but you have to forgive me he says don't
trip you see it's just a really sensible
don't trip he says I'm gonna take it off
your hands for you and when the museum
director protests and says that the work
isn't for sale kill manga retorts how do
you think your ancestors got these do
you think they paid a fair price or did
they take it like they took everything
else and when I saw the film the
audience at that point spontaneously
cheered somehow the African museum
sector has become the pantomime villain
and for me it's difficult it's
impossible for me to digest that we have
such an important story to tell the
oldest story of art the least
appreciated and most under invested we
simply cannot afford to carry this
additional stigma Harbormaster wrote
very affectingly
about how institutions and state suffer
a natural kind of erosion of legitimacy
over time if they do not constantly and
robustly interrogate and nuance their
priorities we've got to think about ways
in which we can interrogate our
priorities our values our remit and
hamamass said that if you don't do that
it leads inevitably to a kind of
disenchantment and perhaps
that is what is begun to happen to our
sector and I think one sense is that
some significant figures within the
sector that they feel that - they've
accepted that this is a time for us to
address a long overdue constellation of
issues and address them head-on to
really examine our profession its past
and the possibilities for the future in
France a report recently commissioned by
President Emmanuel macron recommended
the full restitution by the French
museums of all works in state
collections
taken without consent from former
African colonies but Ron
he seems determined to personify a new
political generation that has no links
to the colonial moment and he's in has
inspired a fascinating study that argues
for the complete transfer of property
back to Africa unless it can be proven
that these objects were acquired
legitimately the report squarely places
the burden of proof of legitimate
acquisition on museums African nations
States municipalities individuals do not
have to petition and prove a valid claim
the German government inspired by the
French have allocated 1.9 million euros
this year to provenance research for
artifacts that entered then at their
national museum collections during the
colonial era an eight-member committee
including two of the co writers of the
french report will select grant
recipients on the basis of applications
from dirt from german museums it's a
very interesting time however the most
important European museums haven't
responded with open arms to this Stephan
Martin the president of K Branly the
French national news museum of
non-western art which holds around
70,000 African works he has pushed back
argue against maximum restitution saying
he would prefer the increased
circulation of African art in
collections rather than their wholesale
return he wants to see more exhibitions
more exchanges loans deposits and
cooperation this has coincided with a
moment when the British Museum that has
long led the charge in curatorial
Cheyney training on the continent has
chosen to step back from its work as its
African Department has been paired back
simultaneously in Belgium they have
reconditioned their old Royal Museum of
Central African art into Verdun with you
know I'm sure you know it's a suburb of
Brussels and they've invested 84 million
dollars in a new suite of galleries to
retell the story of Belgium's deeply
problematic history of brutal Central
African colonialism and it's had a kind
of unforeseen at least by them set of
outcomes
it's reopened debates about colonial era
genocide about government-sponsored
plundering and restitution and the
present king of Belgium a descendent of
Leopold when asked to decided he wasn't
going to attend the opening and rather
than offer catharsis it has inspired
anger in this moment of generational
change there seems to be a lack of
strategic thinking or an enthusiasm to
grasp the opportunities from important
agencies we need to talk our sector
needs to convene meaningful
conversations about collections about
partnerships about loan arrangements and
so much more
whether full scale return occurs or not
we must work to address the imbalance in
resource to find ways to open channels
for better partnerships whilst European
institutions are shifting their focus
that why the sector should not slow the
momentum there is so much more work to
be done in Africa if we are not to be
left in the generation thinking that
this was a lost opportunity to truly
rebuild our sector
the benefit of everyone and one has to
ask what is the state of the current
publicly sponsored sector in Africa and
if Western museums were to institute a
campaign of meaningful restitution if
museums in the West want to begin to
build loan arrangements and acquisition
agreements our African museums even
those beyond the state sector and their
personnel in a position to really
benefit
well we examine the present sector and
the overwhelming unevenness is the big
takeaway Africa boasts a handful of the
very best museums in the world if you
have the opportunity visit sites Makkah
or the Norval foundation in South Africa
both newly opened and it's hard not to
react with or but they sit within a
wider state-sponsored art museum ecology
that remains stubbornly patchy there are
a new generation of Chinese funded State
museums like the Museum of black
civilizations in Senegal but around them
many of the original colonial and
independencia museums have fallen into
disrepair some have been shuttered and
others are poorly visited and a few and
few are in a position to truly safeguard
collections a handful are in a position
to take on loans or broker meaningful
partnerships these things have to change
and the paucity of art history courses
and which are attached to museums or
universities means that narrative is
often initiated and crafted by figures
beyond the continent as ever the markers
of success and recognition continued to
be arbitrated by foreigners this is
frustrating but perhaps there are things
that we might do it might be the
particular convergence of nascent
possibilities offer a generational
opportunity to build the sector that we
would all be proud to be part of it's an
inexact science but we utilize the
reviews on TripAdvisor
as an
approximate relative measure of the
popularity of museums and we agglomerate
the data to enable us to quickly gauge
the relatively relative scale of
audiences and their visitors reactions
the results surprised me the national
wealth and size of population are not a
reflection of Africa's National Museums
health Nigeria Africa's wealthiest
nation a country with a history of
astounding visual arts production and
home to some of the continents most
successful contemporary visual artists
has strangely delivered a kind of uneven
sector and its genuinely under-resourced
and and it has a poorly a poorly visited
state-sponsored museum sector and yet at
the same time nations like Morocco Kenya
Ethiopia they both pockets of really
well visited well-run and well-loved
museums and whilst this unevenness of
provision is concerning this continental
and national patchiness could be the
basis of real hope these figures
suggests that where talented
professionals with reasonable
collections are given a chance they seem
to thrive where governments support the
sector and that resource is catalyzed by
talented professionals magic has really
happened even in regions where there's
been little audience development and
communications investment the quality of
personnel combined with collection has
made the crucial difference occasionally
that spark can be trivalent triggered at
the very top in Benin the president has
led the charge for substantive change
looking at the figures it's stark we
need to help where we can and where we
wanted to be there for those near
isolated institutions and individuals
who are effectively driving the sector
and doing so with little resource or
acknowledgement we must try to grow to
partner to mentor and work with these
wonderful centers of excellence
but mostly we need to listen to learn
how we might change to be better
partners we do need a kind of sectoral
group therapy we need to negotiate new
ways of working together we must invest
in mechanisms to build trust to develop
shared goals and forge a basis for
better future collaboration we are off
we are after all all on the same side
the side of art of our audiences of the
sector but there are important issues to
be addressed even if we accept Stefan
Martin's some somewhat conservative
interpretation of the Matt Crone report
one of parcel partial restitution of
shared programs of exhibitions of
exchanges of loans of deposits and
cooperations even in that pared back
manifestation of sectoral adaptation
there will need to be profound massive
massive changes in African museums to
accommodate these opportunities if we
are not at some point to feel that this
was a missed opportunity fell when saw
an economist at gaston beaujeu
university in san luis Senegal he's the
man who oversaw the research for the
McCrone report he said that we're
proposing a framework that takes into
account the time restraints of the
requesting nations we don't want to
impose a vast quantity of restituted
restituted objects or any country we
want to make sure that they actually
want restitution that their preferred
that they are prepared for it and they
are in a position to organize for it
they hope that restitution they hope
that restitution will actually begin
this year and between now and 22 in 2022
a program of return would have been
delivered for a nation like busy been in
that will be in the development and
reconditioning of the whole suite of
museums between now and well now
actually it's it's there's no time at
all the training of new of a new
generation of experts
and there are plans in place to deliver
this but there is a daunting amount to
do and the British Museum that they've
said that they'll consider everything
except repatriation of objects and
they've recently agreed to a loan of 300
objects of the Benin Museum they've
agreed to share their database which is
and that this is only the beginning as
they say but this happens simultaneously
as a museum service in Lagos suffers a
funding shortfall it does feel like
we're moving toward a substantive
sectoral shift without the provisions in
place to make it sustainable we simply
cannot afford to waste this generational
opportunity I recently lamented in a
long phone call with a colleague at the
British Museum we reflected on how this
would be this could be a wonderful
moment of sectoral Renaissance with new
museums like the JK Randall Center in
Lagos with courses like the new course
at the Institute of Museum Studies at
jaws or the lake on Museum Studies and
course but at the same time there are no
new trained staff to facilitate the
needed change there's limited resource
on the ground and there are tightening
budgets how will things satisfactorily
evolve we remain as ever hopeful and we
are very active at the moment we are
working most meaningfully in Nigeria
Benin and Kenya in Benin we've been
invited to help them consider how they
might reintegrate objects repatriated
from the French national collections to
consider how they'll form the basis of a
number of new and refurbished museums
and it's a bold project that will
require considerable support and
training across every area every area of
traditional museum delivery there's also
the possibility for the Benin Museum
authorities to build a new museum model
for their curators to deploy there
new intern to deploy new interpretive
methodologies for the education programs
to be based on new pedagogy there's no
reason for them to develop museums that
are exactly like ours perhaps they'll be
inspired by by the mobile phone invested
young audiences to renew the museum
paradigm this could be a chance for the
whole sector to grow and we know that
these projects take time we've worked
for a decade now in Edo State in
southern Nigeria working with museum
specialists and officials from the been
in court on a shared exhibition program
and we've seen the real benefits of
long-term partnership in Kenya we're
supporting the development of a new
National Art Museum through which they
hope to rebuild East African art
histories East Africa boasts some of the
most astounding contemporary artists but
has been historically very very poorly
served by its state institutions and
that will change as the British Museum
withdraws its support from these regions
there is an increasingly stark need and
if you have any doubt look online and
observe how few national museums in
Africa have functional websites on a
continent with a very digitally invested
population if you get the chance visit
look at how few have environmental
controls as climate change impacts
buildings buildings ever more corrosive
Lee how few have educational programs on
a continent with a rapidly growing under
25 year old demographic it's concerning
we at the National Museum of Art are a
small institution of 36 permanent staff
but even the possibility of our
engagement with the National Museum
service in Kenya and in Benin has
garnered ministerial support in the case
of Benin the president has been involved
it's because this is needed this is
wanted we we presently partner with
African museums as resource allows but
we would love to partner with others to
do significantly more and that's why I'm
here
I've seen the power of your Africa
initiative and I would love to learn
more it represents a wonderful model for
sectoral intervention intervention a
means of working across multiple areas
of delivery to support change imagine if
we were to supply similar techniques to
the museum sector to augment skills of
museum experts with the skills perhaps
with skills from the business school
imagine what that could bring imagine
the change that might be possible whilst
working alone we as a National Museum we
can ten ibly try to support a handful of
Africa museums in reshaping
institutional visions we can work on the
development of their archives of their
libraries and their conservation
laboratories we can suggest curatorial
and museu logical approaches perhaps
even help with digital digital
communication strategies but imagine if
we could supplement that provision with
legal with financial with development
with buildings and Men and management
advice as needed imagine if we could
work with the big business and
management schools that have knowledge
to support the development of the
African public sector we could transform
lives both Gail and the Smithsonian has
significant strengths presence and
networks in Africa if we were to
collaborate on this it would offer a
chance to deliver at a new level of
impact we are perfect partners there are
synergies in values in history in aims
and built into the mission and culture
of both institutions is a record of
leveraging the power of mutually
beneficial partnerships and global
networks to solve the problems around
the world and I look forward to seeing
future Gail and Smithsonian scholars
working in Africa to strengthen
institutions through great leadership I
know that Yale and Smithsonian scholars
are leading the global consortium for
the preservation of cultural heritage
driving collaboration and mutual
integration among members to assure the
development of the best conditions for
the preservation of the things that we
love our hope is that the consortium
will power the global University through
broad educational programs through major
collaborative research initiatives and
effective engagement and advocacy but
imagine if we were to build on that
model to create a sector wide consortium
to drive real change and collaboration
in the museum sector this might be a
dream but it could begin simply we're
talking testing the possibilities
imagine if we were to initially co-host
the discussion somewhere in Africa and
use it as an opportunity to see if there
might be an appetite for some meaningful
initiatives
perhaps we could test the possibility of
the development of combined courses in
museums management or dynamic research
degrees in which the students were
invested experts who could learn while
sharing their unique knowledge but first
we've got to start talking in a survey
of african museum experts just last year
most museum professionals saw
opportunities to convene and collaborate
as a key aspiration ninety-eight percent
wanted to see a more active museum's
environment and spaces where ideas and
questions could be shared but they don't
have the means to facilitate it we could
convene a discussion and gather
expertise from across Africa Europe and
North America to consider where we are
and where we would like to be in the
longer term those discussions might
catalyze the development of University
supported courses or we might convene a
shared digital space or perhaps a
virtual Center of expertise a space
where we could learn from each other and
lift all boats together we could as we
have in Benin and Kenya work with
ministers and senior civil servants
perhaps starting in pilot areas
with the hope of working more widely
across the continent and beyond in
building solutions and networks to
facilitate deep sectoral change and for
those who sit outside our pilot areas
for those who couldn't afford to travel
we could develop digital resources for
reference and we could build the digital
infrastructure for dynamic engagement
and partnership we could see this as a
wonderful opportunity to engage with the
vast new communities of digitally
engaged museum professionals across the
continent but more widely with those who
are simply open many of whom will never
have the opportunity to travel to travel
but with whom we can share the vast
pleasure and burden of reinterpreting
and reanimating our discipline for the
21st century we could for the very first
time unite communities of interest that
are separated by geography but linked by
passion and we can spend the time to
deliberate on the knotty problems or we
could allow ourselves to be led by the
macro sector defining topics
the choices are ours the Smithsonian the
reason I joined it was created for the
dissemination for the diffusion of
knowledge we were contrived in major
part as a cultural mechanism to change
hearts and minds to inspire and lift
discourse and today we have the tools in
our hands the tools available to us to
deliver to our original remit at a scale
and with a flexibility unimaginable to
our forebears we can as a National
Museum engage meaningfully in truly go
global conversations and for me the idea
that the benefit of museum collections
to be the preserve of those limited few
who live within the proximity of a
well-funded museum that our thinking
should be driven and directed toward the
financially or the educated or the
educationally privileged I think that
runs counter to the spirit upon which
most modern museums were found
and through this program we wouldn't
just benef just widen the benefit we
could give back to the very communities
from which our collections were drawn
I think Smithson as a Brit who gave
money to fund a museum in a country he
had never visited because he wanted to
catalyze learning I think he would have
liked that much of this isn't new not
the problems nor indeed the obvious
solutions in the 90s in response to
criticism from many constituencies the
World Bank began including environmental
groups and NGOs in its loans to mitigate
some of the past effects of its
development policies and it very briefly
it looked at culture in Africa and how
it might be a catalyzing force for
delivering both meaningful development
and for shifting hearts and minds and
beyond UNESCO x' brief of preservation
and education the World Bank saw an
additional role for culture as important
in fostering social cohesion a kind of
social cohesion that underpins healthy
economies many argued that in the West
culture was treated and nurtured as an
industry and it seemed to work and when
supported through education through
state-sponsored sponsors through the
state sponsorship of blue-ribbon
projects it was an important component
of a successful economy of a cohesive
society and what those successful
Western museums shared was being
meaningful meaningfully relevant to
their constituents there was a World
Bank recommendation as part of that
report that African museums should no
longer blindly imitate Western models
but they should become something of
their own tools for the improvement of
their own communities evolving into
flexible entities able to facilitate and
celebrate both the terrible material and
intangible heritage in their own way and
was hope there was a kind of hope that
beyond culture museums might grow to
potentially address issues like health
like urbanization like environmental
degradation and political evolution and
they could become engines for real
catharsis and drive social cohesion that
1990s vision that World Bank vision it
remains a good one with the explosion of
digital possibilities the potential for
museum engagement has been further
transformed these programs sadly went
out a favor with the era of the NGO in
the late 90s but I think we need to
rescue the baby from the discarded
bathwater
we need to remake remake the economic
case for investment in African heritage
I believe the arts that arts and
heritage could be a driver for real
social cohesion and national stability
in many areas of Africa and it could
become a real engine of job job creation
and and also it could impact directly
subsidiary sectors it has the potential
to deliver even wider economic benefits
and think of how it might impact tourism
and delivering deep sectoral change it's
only in part about money our sector is
delivered a number of these kinds of
training programs over generations to
attempt to alleviate the seemingly
intractable problems and we work to
refurbish and to develop real estate and
facilities in a variety of regions but
limited training and infrastructure
schemes simply have proven not to be
enough there have been countless schemes
to train personnel to invest in talent
however none have looked at the sector
holistically none have had the benefit
of such favorable political of such a
favorable political landscape or the
possibility of restitution also we've
never had such a favorable cold
ambience a moment when change is
categorically less challenging than
stasis this is an exceptional
opportunity for us to adjust the
fundamental model of our discipline the
nature of ambition and the very tenor of
what we do and as ever it's not just
Africans that need to adapt we must all
learn to be better partners to
reconfigure the figure models of
ownership and collaboration to perhaps
allow time and space to grieve to
express anger maybe remorse but
critically to rebuild trust respect and
understanding we must invest in making
the sector feel united by accepted
standards by ethical codes by
considering sectoral values through
nurturing sympathetic cultures and
underlying share an aunt and an
underlying shared love of African art I
think we can build a new sort of respect
for each other and I began by describing
the loss of narrative a voice well
please let's start talking let's fill
the void with voices and although it's
tempting please let's not retreat let's
hear from the old old wise heads but
also let's make space for new voices for
new ideas let's listen to the long
ignored and the quiet let's together
craft a new moment convene a shared
conversation truly shape and to reshape
our understanding of African art the
perverse imbalance in resource in
expertise and in collections between
museums on the continent and those
beyond it isn't just damaged museums in
Africa the very moral authority of many
museums across the Western world has
been quite rightly questioned by many
who feel that
change is long overdue please let's
listen thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yes the our museum National Museum
African art is really I mean like so
many museums it's it's the drive of a
single individual Warren Robbins and he
recognized in African art particularly
if you imagine that this was in the
early 60s that there could be a
mechanism for catalyzing discussion
between polarized communities within
Washington and beyond and if you imagine
1963-64 that this is the moment of of
new human rights legislation of new race
relations legislation of roe versus wade
huge changes in the way in which we
understood how we dealt with one another
and he wanted to broker through culture
a new opportunity for us to think about
our relationship to to Africa and
particularly as a mechanism for
empowering peoples of African descent
and that was its initial focus and it
was conceived with incredible ambition
from it's very beginning because within
a couple of years of being opened that a
piece of art the FO accom which is which
was a wonderful Cameroonians
wooden sculpture was stolen from a
shrine in Cameroon and it ends up in
North America and it is figures in and
around our Museum
that fight for the return of that that
object that tried to raise the money for
its acquisition for its return and so I
think from it's very beginning it was
driven by this idea of engagement with
the continent of equitable relationships
not of collecting collecting voraciously
for its own sake but of finding ways of
building relationships that were really
meaningful but particularly doing that
to drive the idea of Africa being a
culture that we should all have
knowledge with knowledge of and engage
with and I think Warren Robbins our
founder if he were alive today he would
be wanting us to use digital engagement
he would be wanting us to form those
partnerships on the continent so that we
can broker a new moment in which we
deliver that vision but deliver it at a
sort of global level of delivery because
I remember when I first came to New
Haven and I went to the Year at gallery
and seen all these artifacts I was blown
out because those I did like I'm from
Nigeria and for my childhood those
oddities that we'll be reading in
European books that we've never seen
before and then coming to the air our
gallery on going to the Metropolitan
Museum has seen those things visa vie I
was also surprised and I think that it
would be great for this artifact to be
seen by the generations that have only
heard about it and they've never seen it
and also I do believe that because those
artifacts but we're not just for the
sake of beauty the way others that
people were worshipping so it has its
own spiritual values and those spiritual
value
are still existing into the idols and
sometimes I am amazed how people look at
it as a new coating or a beautiful
object as to a spiritual entity I only
think that there is a wonderful
opportunity for us to engage with a wide
variety of constituencies not just in
North America that you know across
particularly the Western world that
there are so many communities that are
divided and polarized the route on on
ethnic lines and our institution was
initially it will it came into being to
begin to try to build bridges but I
would love to see our institution
working transcontinental II to build
bridges to find ways of convening
conversations around these amazing
pieces of work and I think many of the
questions around the disparities in the
size of collections around restitution
and these are things that we can work
through over a generation that we can
begin to share objects that we can begin
to we can begin to build a new
generation of museums across the
continent will mean that we can actually
have shared acquisition policies as well
that I think if we build a new moment in
which there is that trust
it would mean not only that there are
benefits for people who visit museums
across the continent in that they will
be getting they were getting toward
shows but they will also be having kind
of long-term loans of objects that there
may well be the restitution of objects
but it will also mean that for us in
terms of the reinterpretation of our
collection that we will have a whole
body of possibilities of expertise of
people who are in variety of ways
invested in thinking about these sorts
of objects in ways that we could not
possibly and I think that for me is
enormous ly excited
and I think that is absolutely that is
absolutely in tune with the the drives
that Warren Robbins had when he founded
our institution
I think just as you're talking about a
new generation of scholars and an
interest in engaging with the African
continent I think there's a new
generation of people inheriting private
collections and wondering how they can
responsibly have these objects and my
question is how can the museum help to
kind of foster assure a way that people
with private collections can also be
part of this dialogue or also maybe even
part of either repatriation or sharing
these objects so that they're not kind
of cloistered in the way that they've
traditionally been in private
collections well I love that as an idea
I mean that we've delivered this survey
which we've been trying to chart the
numbers of museums and the quality of
delivery across the African continent
and there simply aren't that many
museums there are particularly art
museums there are few enough that we
could much more equitably think of ways
in which we could share collections that
we can work together that we can work on
loans but also I absolutely agree that
there is an opportunity for us to think
about ways in which we encourage those
people who inherit those people who get
to a point where they want to relinquish
their collections that we could find
ways of them finding parts back to two
homes in Africa and I think that would
be something which would it would
actually kind of not just be good for
the peoples of Africa but I think it
would actually be cathartic for for many
people who have these collections it
would be a wonderful way of thinking of
these objects having a new chapter of
their life
[Applause]
[Music]